c'est le traitement le plus merveilleux est un
moment magique plein d'émerveillement J'apprécie un
moment pour créer des souvenirs durables de
famille et d'amis à nouveau le
secret de ce qui rend Noël si spécial
certains b-boy ont l'impression que des
seins géants tombent de novembre au Nouvel
An et c'est notre période la plus occupée de
l'année au travail.
Noël ouais, j'ai dit des
mois pour choisir le cadeau parfait
pour tout le monde, nous savons que la seule chose que je
reçois en retour
coupon pour un frottement gratuit du dos, ce n'est pas correct,
merde, rappelez-vous quand les
vacances se sont bien passées, la victime
et le retour de Noël, où est ton
arbre je  Je n'aimais pas perdre de temps à
acheter des arbres de Noël. Je voulais en fait profiter de
Noël. Amy, tu es une maman.
c]
maintenant la maison a l'air vraiment belle oh
merci ton père est génial elle a dit l'
histoire pourquoi diriez-vous que je t'ai entendu
toi et papa dans la chambre tu peux te
laver les mains donc la porte juste un
cri super heureux et puis tu frappes le mur
et crie  le F êtes-vous comme oh mon
[ __ ] de dieu juste comme ça oh mon [ __ ] de
dieu oh mon dieu
toi
[Musique]